Hey guys I am Grant Thompson The King of Random. Welcome back to King's court number two and today
I do have a joke for [you] this one's from my six-year-old son!
He says what do clouds wear under their clothes the answer of course?
[Thunder] [wear]
First of all I just want to thank all of you who are in the comments a couple of weeks ago
It was very very encouraging [for] me to hear your feedback
99.9% of what I saw on there was really encouraging a really faith promoting and it really
Launched me into a new level with my channel and what I want to do and where things are going
I'm really excited to tell you about some of those things today now
I have been in the kitchen for the last three days making candy for you
I'm going to be at CVX live on Friday and Saturday the 25th and the 26th
And I've got chocolate Lego that. I've just put together for anyone who comes to see me
[they're] [100%] edible they stack together
And they're all different colors
Not only that but I've got bowl fulls here of gummy candies that I'm in the process of making as well
So we're going to have gummy legos chocolate legos, and I've got no real agenda except just to hang out and talk to you
So come and see me this Friday and Saturday at CVX live now. Here's a quick [update] on
What's been happening the last couple weeks since we talked [last] because I haven't been sitting around doing nothing
I've actually been working on scripts videos production so as of [today]. I actually have 17 videos that are produced and uploaded and
Scheduled to go out eight of those [are] project videos nine of those are quick clips
And I have another 11 videos that are in various stages of [production] right now. They're coming up, so that's 28 videos
That's enough content to last me till october right now and with that buffer my plan is to get a production team [to] come in
help me with my video editing so that I can produce even more and maybe jump to two times a week or three times a
Week if [possible] I don't want to over promise and under deliver, but that's what my hope and my ambition is right now
I just launched my own patreon page this morning. I put the link in the description so you can go check it out
This is how we're going to launch it to the next level and you're one of my team players for those of you who may?
Not be familiar with patreon. It's a site where you can donate to me as a creator so I can outsource some of the
Labor-intensive things that I'm doing and focus more on the creative projects and videos to bring to you
It's basically a way for you to help me create more content for you
So it's a win-win if I can find a small production company to take over my video production
That's going to free up about 70% of my time work on new projects to bring to you
And here's my promise to you with every dollar that gets donated to me through patreon
I will invest 100% of that back into you and that [queue] of 17 videos I have right [now] that are
Unlisted some of you are going to get to see all [of] those weeks
And even months before they go live
I've never asked for donations before because I haven't really felt right about it
But this is a way that I truly feel like we can make it a win-win situation
[you're] going to help me take the channel to a whole nother level
[and] I'm going to be able to give you content and rewards that I wouldn't be able to do otherwise and if you want to
Give, but you don't have any money to give that's okay. Don't feel bad
I still appreciate you, and I'm just glad that you're here supporting me [on] YouTube because everything helps bigger small all right
So I've got ten new frequently asked questions that I'm going to address in this video, but if you have more questions
Make sure you put them in the comments
I will see those I'll pick them out [and] I'll put them in future episodes [so] one of the questions
I get a lot is are you ever going to go on TV?
And the answer is probably not over the last three [years] I've actually had over 200
television production companies contact me about doing shows for discovery history
Spike and every other TV network out there, which sounds really attractive, but the thing is in television
Nobody really wants to pay you they expect you to work for free they want you work for exposure?
and I'm not in a position where I can just take two or three years off to do a couple seasons and
Just work for free to see what happens. I'm here with you. I'm making videos for you
I don't have time for TV. And if they're not going to pay [for] my time
It doesn't [really] seem practical the other unfortunate thing about TV is people aren't watching it as much
More people are shifting to the internet
So [I] feel like being here with you on the internet is probably one of the best places that I can be right now
television almost seems a little bit counterproductive
Another question says why don't you do life hack [videos] anymore?
And I know it can see that way and honestly I do have a lot of life hack videos already made and coming up that
You haven't seen yet, but this last year
It's been [a] little thin because I've had some passion projects like the whole rocket building series and the styro-slicer' that I really needed to
Get done, so I put on the blinders
And I focused through that
But they're all finished now, and so we're moving into next phase, and you will see a lot more life hack videos coming up
Thank you what camera gear [and] what editing software. Do you use now surprisingly? I'm still using the same [camera]
I started using from day one. It's a canon t4I
DsLR camera and get off ebay for about $500 the editing soft where I use is called Adobe Premiere pro. It used to be about
$2,700 for the whole master suite, but now they've got a monthly option for [$50.00] where you can access everything on a
monthly
Basis, what was your favorite project?
That's a great question I get asked that all the time my favorite project is all of them
And I know that might sound a little bit cliche, but every project
I learned something new every [project] that I've ever done has taught me something new and I feel like I've grown as a result of
That and so every project to me is very meaningful. It's very purposeful. I guess contrary to some people's beliefs
I don't know how to do all these [things] from the beginning. I have to figure them out
so every project is a challenge for me and the video is kind of like a
completion of that challenge once I figured it out made a video that's kind of like the culmination of all my experience has gone into
It so I love all my projects for different reasons, but of course
I'm really proud of ones that go popular like the magic mud Lego gummies Ninja balls things that people can do at home
I love all those for me personally
I like the projects that push me like I like making Arc welders out of microwaves because that was different [out-Of-the-box] thinking
But there's a little bit of a line
I have to draw there because not necessarily everything that interests me is appropriate for the internet
so I have to be really careful about how I present things because we're all in different levels of learning and
some people are above me and some people are below me and I'm just trying to present my
Experiences through my videos and my goal is to make every video a masterpiece [a] lot of people have wondered
why do you post a quick clip when you're going to use the same footage again in the
Tutorial and I probably am going to address this in a whole different video. I have 10 really good reasons
Why I feel I should have quick clips, but the really short answer is basically because it allows me to post videos more regularly
while still working on high quality videos if I only put out videos as I [finish] them every 10 days then YouTube's
algorithms are going to kind of kick my channel out and it's not going to benefit anybody by posting quick clips it gives you a
Preview of what's coming up and at the same time?
It helps fill the gap between my project videos, so it keeps my channel a little more regular another viewer asks
Have you ever gotten or [heard] from one of the things you've made and the answer is yes?
And it's this finger right here
If you saw my video on making the ARc furnace you know at the very end of the video
I had a copper khan solo in carbonite
And when I was actually cutting the wax for that mold I had a kitchen knife and somehow. I'm not really sure how it happened
that knife went straight into my finger and cut through the nerves and
Almost took my finger right off actually it's been over a year now and I can bend it to there
I still don't have full use of it
And I've tried to hide it pretty well in my videos went about halfway through it severed the nerves
[I] still don't have feeling in my fingertip, but I actually am pretty lucky with what I've cut here
And it doesn't really hold me back that much I can still type
I could still edit and I almost have full use of my finger. I just can't feel anything in the fingertip right now
This is a question that popped up a couple times in my last video
And it's really appropriate is why don't you get a patreon page and hire an editor so perfect [I] took your advice
I got a patreon page
and I'm in the process of interviewing quite a few different editors and
hopefully one [of] them is going to stick and be able to take over producing top quality content and
Allow me more free time. [are] you an engineer? [I] am not an engineer. I have no engineering qualifications whatsoever
Everything that I do is I guess based on trial and error and then when I present things
It's what's worked a lot of the things that [I] fail on you
Don't see and I fail on a lot of things before I even film them
I do my own projects five to ten times before I even turn on the camera so a lot of the bloopers and the fails
You don't even see because I never even have the camera running
It's not until I've got the project nearly
Perfected that I turn on a camera and actually start filming it this is a good question how much do you spend on [your] projects?
And the answer is a lot more than you think even when I'm doing a simple little project like what I've been prototyping this week
Was just basically how to make a chocolate milkshake
[I] spent over a [hundred] dollars in materials on ice cream and cocoa powder and sweetened condensed milk [a] lot of different things because I'm
Experimenting, and I've done like 15 different experiments with different variations, and I haven't even turned the camera on yet
And I'll probably blow through more money before I'm actually finished but my goal. Is that when I present the video to you
It's tried tested and true and [that] means I can't just take anything that I hear at face value
I need to experiment with it. You know I've got recipes
I found online, but I've done 15 of my own experiments
and I don't like any of the recipes that I found I'm trying to make my own [so] sometimes it's 100 200 sometimes it's
$1,000 per project my mini Metal foundry
I went through 10 prototypes, and you know if you add that up
It's probably well over [$1,000] just to come up with a version most people can do at [home] for 20 bucks
So I do actually spend a lot [of] money on my project hundreds of dollars
But that all goes into the prototyping and finding ways to cut cost so that when I bring
The video it can be done as cheaply and as quickly with as little materials as possible
[and] the last question here where do you buy liquid nitrogen good question now for [me]?
I actually have a liquid nitrogen generator in my basement
[have] a good friend that helped me set that up, but before I had my own liquid nitrogen generator
[I] went to air gas suppliers welding suppliers any industrial gas supplier
That sells gas to like argon or helium is probably going to have nitrogen as well
So just call them up ask them if they sell liquid nitrogen chances are you're going to have to be over 18 [or] 21
they are going to charge you quite a bit of money for it and we're from five to ten dollars [a] litre and
You're going to have to have your own stainless steel dewar
Which can be up to four hundred dollars so if you got all those things by all means go get yourself some liquid nitrogen
So that's pretty much it for questions this time as far as expectations go two weeks from now
I'm going to get back to posting my videos on a regular schedule at least every week
And they're not going to stop again after that this next two weeks
I'm going to be looking for production crews and trying to put all the systems into place to making this super sustainable going forward
[so] if you have any other ideas on how we can take this channel to the next level I'm talking about you and me let
Me know in the comments below let me know if you've got some insight on how we can make this thing bigger than myself
I know, I've just got to get myself out [of] the way, and I'm working on doing that right now
And I appreciate your support come see me at CVX live Friday and Saturday
I'd still like to meet you, and I've got some treats
You know tons and tons of treats that I want to give away so at least come for those if not for me and come
see me on Patreon any level of support that you [can] give me is going to allow me to give back to you and
Again, I promise that all the money that comes to me on Patreon will not be going in my pocket
But would turn around and go [right] [back] into the channel the content and giveaways [for] you
This is really about you
And I'm looking for ways [to] expand what I can give and so thank you in advance for your support [well]
I'm all out of time so I need to wrap things up, but I will see you in the next project video
They'll be posting in two weeks. I'll see you then
you